what is happening there citizens of the
reject Nation Greg and John here today
we are going to watch the new rock stars
Easter egg breakdown for black panther
wakana forever we've just finished a
little more than a three hour live
stream talking about wakana forever now
I got it ourselves 40 minutes of Eric
Voss to tell us everything we didn't
talk about guys uh leave a like follow
new rock stars and you can check out
that live stream let's get into it
[Music]
rockstars I'm and this is a breakdown of
black panther what kind of forever a
film that teaches us how in grief there
is power in a truly remarkable feat of
Cinema to advance the thematically rich
thought experiment of wakanda somehow
without its beloved hero t'challa the
late Chadwick Boseman we must dive deep
into this film to celebrate how director
Ryan coogler pulled this off breaking it
down scene by scene not just for the
marble Easter eggs really for what I
consider to be even more rewarding and
easier to overlook filmmaking choices
spoilers what who cares about those
please allow me to heal my brother now
of course boss is a panther deity of
wakanda the entity that endows the Black
Panther with their powers she prays
because she needs to regrow the
heart-shaped herb all of which was
burned by killmonger in the 2018 film
and boss is believed to be the spiritual
source of that herb sure he scrambles in
her lab to heal t'challa by regrowing
this herb synthetically with her AI
griot voiced by Trevor Noah oh what I
had no idea
the whole time and it's funny Andrew
commented to me yesterday that the
credits moved so fast and I yeah I
totally didn't catch it and would never
have uh realized this oh my God that's
so cool what it's a gripping 90-second
long take no cutting documentary style
underscoring this is a true medical
emergency now the Herb's DNA is shown in
a double helix configuration with white
orbs while the 2018 film opened with
grains of black this is orbs of white
already cast in the wakandan color of
mourning reports of the DNA points
says good enough and orders it 3D
printed but her mother Ramona enters to
report your brother is with the
ancestors now t'challa's illness is
never specified in his film out of
respect to the late Chadwick Boseman
whose death in August 2020 after a
private battle with colon cancer
prompted a rewrite of the script this
way Ryan coogler and co-writer Joe
Robert Cole avoid exploiting Bozeman's
death as a plot point or a spectacle
piece it's not really about how t'challa
died it's about how to mourn and so by
using simply the word illness
Cosmic MCU battle but really a more
grounded way that many of us have lost
our loved ones and truly the way that we
lost Chadwick sure is our focal
character for this story and this movie
evolves her is comic relief Kid Sister
to a true instrument of grief who
through her journey teaches us how to
heal ourselves because while she's
really trying to heal her brother in the
opening minutes her true mission of this
film is to heal herself like the proverb
physician heal thyself shuri's wounds
will only be treated when she takes the
remedy that she's trying to produce for
her brother and once she properly
Grieves her lost family Bost answers her
prayers with t'challa's Legacy okay see
that's part of why I find this movie so
beautiful is because like what Eric
wanted it out too is that it's more than
just mourning the loss of Chadwick
Boseman there is a catharsis to be had
for as most of us I've imagined most of
us have lost someone in our lives in a
lot of ways you know this is that
catharsis like for me it's been a been a
few years since I've really lost someone
that was impactful and instrumental in
my development however I would say that
there is something a bit of a true
connection that feels heard and listened
to when I watch something like this and
I think that's why it hits me so strong
t'challa is buried in a private family
plot as water is poured in soil
hydrating this plot we're sure we'll
later plant future heart-shaped herbs
shapeway the shaman successor to
spiritual Elder Zuri in the 2018 film in
Terrace t'challa as the son of t'chaka
in the descendant of bashenga the first
black panther and while it's all in
wakandan the term black panther is in
English suggesting that like Namor this
is a name given to the hero by The
Outsiders of this world while t'challa
himself is buried here is paraded
through the streets of the golden sea of
wakanda a festive celebration of life
shuri Ramona and all the wakandans wear
the color white as they did while they
were mourning to Chaka in the 2018 film
we passed a naval guard playing a water
drum which is a cameo by Jabari Exum a
drumming and movement coach from the
2018 film and a friend of Chadwick
boseman's whom Lupita nyongo said would
drum while they did their fight training
or this movie oh that's so cool part of
their Rhythm one way now trying to keep
Chadwick's Spirit fighting alongside
them in this movie a tribute billboard
oh that's beautiful translates to the
panther king forever lives in us and
rests with the ancestors overhead
wakanda Jets crisscross in a flyover
leaving
like the wakandan chest salute the Royal
Cemetery gate is flanked by statues of
bashenga on one side and a female on the
other both of whom have Panther statues
at their feet the female could be
bashanka's wife or her sister either way
both t'challa's sister and his wife play
key roles in Burger in his legacy as
they salute his good symbolism music is
ludwigsen's ancestral plain theme to me
the most powerful Melody from his
oscar-winning score it's the music
t'challa heard when he entered the
ancestral plane to join his ancestors in
the 2018 film and it's the music he and
we here now and then under reverence
silence the Marvel Studios Fanfare
replaces typical imagery of Avengers
with moments and Script quotes from
Chadwick Postman s t'challa first the
script quote in Civil War when he told
Natasha about the green field with
Boston segment after his father died
then our very first shot of Chadwick in
the MCU when he looked over his shoulder
when he was in Vienna in Civil War then
t'challa in a suit with his mask off
then the script quote t'chella asked his
father in The ancestral plane tell me
how to best protect wakanda I want to be
a great king then the script quote
t'challa said before the U.N in times of
Crisis the wise build Bridges while the
foolish build barriers then an image of
black panther with a mask on then the
script quote what happens now determines
what happens to the rest of the world
which I think was just a line for the
Black Panther trailer marketing
throughout 2017 and 2018 then the script
quote if anyone found out what we truly
are and what we possess they could
destroy the world it's my duty to
protect it which is an alternate line
for the movie that t'challa said to
Nakia when they walk through the streets
in Black Panther and then t'challa
Crossing his arms in salute then we see
the letters of Marvel Studios where the
flickering images are more famous
moments of t'challa yeah I'm gonna be
honest I did not notice did you notice
The Script quotes at all I didn't
process them it's like yeah I saw the
words and I think in the back of my mind
I was just like oh they're always there
but yeah and especially it's fascinating
that they would pull alternate quotes or
or moments that didn't actually like
appear in the movie like I feel like
there has to be some level of intent
there but yeah I didn't process that
they were his lines certainly well I
mean a big part of actors is they make
lines their own so if there's like an
alternate take I could imagine that it
was just the way he decided to deliver
that line or choose some of his own
grammar in the moment because sometimes
you might change it just a tiny bit in
this verb being in the moment I think it
was kind of cool that they chose the
original lines that he would have to
work off of to birth his character
highlights yeah his interaction with the
process too yeah t'challa walking
Industries lab in the 2018 film t'challa
celebrating at Warrior Falls after he
defeated mbaku t'challa hugging his
father to Chaka in the ancestral plane
in the 2018 film The Moment t'challa
drops out of the royal Talon fighter to
help Nakia in the 2018 film then on the
inside of the V to Chala swinging from
the Rhino horn in the battle of the 2018
film then on the r to challenge shuri
stepping out of the portal in endgame to
give cap some backup and then on the M
t'challa shouting the words wakanda
forever an Infinity War right before the
charge and it ends as it has throughout
many phase four titles clearing all of
these images with t'challa punching the
ground to release the shock wave and
behind all this is a purple Hue the
color of the heart-shaped herb fitting
beautiful and poignant tribute we
transitioned one year later Queen Ramona
played by Angela Bassett in a powerful
truly osworthy performance addresses the
U.S who tries to shame her for not
sharing what kind of vibranium with the
outside world Richard Schiff Toby
Ziegler from The West Wing is credited
as the U.S Secretary of State an office
switched during the Civil War era was
held by Thaddeus Ross in the MCU rip to
Thunderbolt Ross William Hurt as well as
leader of the merchant tribe Dorothy
Steele who plays a small role in this
movie but also died during production
the French secretary States right the
vibranium cannot be detected by known
metal detectors as we saw in the 2018
film when t'challa Nakia and nokoye
entered that Korean nightclub Ramona
defends the wakandan's actions as
safeguards against the hostility of
other nations saint she knows they
whispered the king is dead the Black
Panther is gone and now is the time to
strike calling out there Trails of their
Goodwill the last time wakanda appeared
before the U.N and we actually see these
actions at a wakandan Outreach Center in
onsongo Mali one of the many Outreach
centers to challengeuri opened around
the world including one in Oakland that
we saw at the end of the 2018 film oh
yeah whatever happens that Oakland
Outreach Center I don't know I mean I
feel like they could use it down the
line and I feel like if Ryan coogler
comes back it would be interesting to
see because Oakland is you know he's I
think he grew up there and is a big part
of his you know stories so I feel like
it was very intentional to place one
there so I mean there's stuff you could
do with that in the future it still
carries on with Nokia helping out people
in Haiti they did end the movie with the
for the last one with that yeah so I
thought they would carry through with
that in some way here maybe the shuri
will go and protect Oakland while umbaku
watches uh wakanda French Commandos
attack these scientists but a koi leads
dorm Elijah to the rescue and we find
out that one of these signs is actually
one of the dormologically undercover
Anika played by Michaela Cole she uses
vibranium daggers against okoya's
insistence I want to see more of her I
may destroy you have someone here
suggested they must have anticipated
this attack and or other Outreach
centers have already been raided and we
learn in a Twist this attack had already
happened hours before the U.N speech so
the dorm Elijah escort these Commandos
to the U.N to shame the French
shame the French
to this incursion
be an olive branch yeah okoya is French
and other non-english languages in this
movie it's translated into subtitles the
color white wakandan is always
translated into yellow and the language
italocon is translated into blue and of
course it's hard to hear the word
incursion in the MCU not think of Reed
Richards warning us about incursions
heading to Secret Wars and multicrous
Madness we should note that in the 2015
John Hickman New Avengers run that kicks
off that Illuminati freakout over
incursions that seems to be Marvel
Studios road map for how we're leading
to that the initial incursion Point
appears where over the Skies over
wakanda then on to an ocean Expedition
that's what Angela Bassett was talking
about the kind vibranium detector to
investigate an underwater drill that got
busted on a deposit of vibranium they're
led by Dr Graham actress Lake Bell who
voices Natasha Romanov on what if the
telecon Warriors Dart passed them in the
shadows and we hear louder and louder
their siren song the diver Salazar and
Jackson get transfixed by a phantom
jellyfish before the teleconians kill
them I gotta imagine this was at least a
nod from Kugler to Jordan peel for the
jellyfish inspired UFO jeans jacket and
nope which hypnotically led people but
we got a note in this movie not that
kind of Doom I mean and it's hard for me
to imagine that considering they both
came out this year yeah and I mean yeah
the jellyfish makes a lot of sense to be
down there and they do make other
allusions to jellyfish in this movie
specifically so it felt more motivated
internally than if it's that's the
Jordan Peele tribute I would have never
spotted it and I would absolutely have
needed someone to suggest that the
teleconians break the surface of the
water and sing hypnotizing crew members
to walk off the deck into the water this
is based on Sirens of Greek mythology
humanoid creatures who would lure
Sailors to their Shores with their songs
but then cause those Sailors to crash on
the rocks of the islands a Tuma nomura
and other telekines bore the ship in
attack in the comics atuma is a rival to
Namor but here he's kind of a second in
command wow that sounds like a massive
change yep learning a lot today about
how much neymore and Company have
changed and especially I mean like it
makes it's really cool the way they
orchestrate his beef with akoye but at
the same time I'm like we did get that
name we're moving maybe that'll be the
conflict be a little bit like what
happened internally moving going wrong
in Black Panther the first one you know
when there were alliances forming
against within the kingdom itself yeah
exactly and then you know like he has to
convince namura at the end so maybe a
Tuma comes in he's like I don't buy that
yeah he's weak yeah I'm gonna take over
now lead with strength they all wear
breathing masks filled with water so
that they can move on land similar to
the moisture masks of the still suits in
Doom Dr Graham departs in a helicopter
but it crashes revealed to have been
thrown by its tail by Namor flying with
his ankle wings and we cross dissolve
from this into the border of wakanda
making it look like no more is flying
into that Kingdom as this will be the
next place he visits going to wakanda
right now Cooper cameos reported on the
U.N speech you look closely at the
ticker along the bottom of the screen it
reads Scott Lane continues to promote
his book look out for the little
I don't think that's it at all which of
course is the next film on Marvel
studioslate Ramona finds that's an
Easter egg we're sure he's designing the
EXO suits that will eventually become
okoye's Midnight Angel suits the wakanda
letters on shuri's screen translate to
Flat Line which might just be one of her
design template tool option but also
might just be an unfortunate word
combination reminding her of how a year
earlier she found out her brother
flatlined in the same spot yeah the
Ramona says that the AI agree out a
nerves her saying one day artificial
intelligence is going to kill us all and
sure he says AI isn't like the movie's
mother it does exactly what I tell it
Age of Ultron pretty unexchange for a
world that has definitely had to deal
with ultra yeah she wants to take her on
a trip telling her to leave behind her
because bracelet and her kaboyo earrings
setting up Sherry to have two separate
ways of tracking her after she leaves
behind her bracelet on the bridge Ramona
takes shuri to a Riverside campfire to
partake in a morning ritual of Bernie in
the funeral garments I think that's
really smart to do that too because
there's like no form of real protection
they have other than the Spears and
Neymar shows up yeah it's very Elemental
that way it's very vulnerable for them
in that situation nearby elephants
bathed in the river elephants are known
to have complex grieving rituals as well
traveling long distances to the sites on
the anniversaries of the deaths of
family members Guided by an instinct
similar to the hand of t'challa's spirit
that Ramona mentions here but sure he
always a scientist is a skeptic I gotta
point this out did you hear that story a
couple months ago where I think it was
an elephant's parent or elephant's child
was um you know uh murdered and then uh
the elephant found the one who did it
killed him and then when the funeral
took place later the at the same
elephant came back and stamped through
that funeral what yeah that's ins
elephants are known to have us they're
in a strong memory and yes they are
extremely extremely emotional the John
Wick of elephants
I want that Revenge movie elephant is
not messing around man she says the hand
was a construct of Ramona's mind shuri
says if I sit here and think about my
brother for too long it won't be these
clothes I burn it will be the world and
everyone in it now later when shuri
enters the ancestral plane she wears
these funeral garments as the room
around her catches fire so in this
moment she talks about birding the world
she is invoking killmonger and his rage
Ramona nearly tells sharia's secret
about t'challa they are interrupted by
Namor now the comics Namor was the
Submariner ruler of Atlantis Marvel's
first mutant when he was introduced in
timely Comics 1939 but here the
character's been reconceled by Ryan
coogler to be played by tenochuerta from
the realm of telecon but still having
the pointy ears and the ankle Wings
Nemours says yeah this place is amazing
the air is pristine damn is this scene
online
my mother told stories about a place
like this a protected land with people
that never had to leave
never have to change who they were
what reason do you have to rebuild your
secret to the world I am not a woman who
enjoys repeating herself
who are you I have many names
my people
oh Google God
well my enemies call me no more is The
Feathered Serpent deity worshiped by the
ancient Mayans
an Aztec afterlife that takes in those
who die from drowning or anything
associated with rain or water the native
language
is based on ancient Mayan languages sure
he observes that horizontal vibranium
meaning that she could just kind of
eyeball his metallic chess pieces and
pearls and tell that they are all
vibranium despite their different color
and texture from the vibranium she works
with she's such an expert she just knows
vibranium when she sees it and the more
leaves ramonda with the American
vibranium detector and a vibranium conch
shell to call him and I just love this
oh it's vibranium this is what I was
told as a Florida kid that when you put
a shell up to your ear you can hear the
ocean nope you're really hearing them
all the Council of Elders gatherers
tribe the Elders of the River tribe
carrot and baku's carrots Baku enters
this room he eats him a call back to his
line in the 2018 film one more word and
I will feed you to my children
I'm kidding we have vegetarians the door
milage stand on columns for the
different parts of the Kingdom on the
columns are written Golden City
kingsguard River tribe mining tribe
behind each guard are the Tableau
symbols in red clay just like the floor
of this throne room they originally
designed this throne room so we made it
the same clay so that all the different
rulers of the different tribes would all
stand on the same terrain one of these
symbols is a large tree with expansive
branches and equally expansive roots in
the past I've gone through this to the
each or so worlds tree of Asgardian
mythology but in this case I like the
symbolism of As Above So Below as above
we have the kingdom of wakanda as below
we have the kingdom of talukan now
behind each door milage Garden
rest in Power King t'challa our hero
twas an honor wakanda forever wow wow
really oh that's beautiful people gonna
get that tattooed loyalty actor Isaac
debeccalay plays the River tribe Elder
as he did in the 2018 film and surmises
that no more must have swum he says 100
kilometers to bypass the River border
makes us Wonder a bit about the wakanda
feed because it is certainly more than
100 kilometers to the nearest ocean or
sea based on the map of wakanda from
Civil War but it would be within 100
kilometers of Lake Victoria which would
be a nearby lake that no more could swim
to up the Nile for the Mediterranean Sea
working on this geography in other
videos but I think the math does check
out there I don't even think Kevin feige
knows where exactly where it's located I
think the Vegas like Springfield the
vagueness is your is your asset
somewhere somewhere in Africa yeah yeah
you know where where's is it connectable
by a river or another body of water you
know that's fine then yeah I don't think
we're ever gonna know exactly where it's
located yeah
it's not a real place people
[Laughter]
technically only one and nowhere else
Ramona Sherry nikoye deduce that there
must have been a second vibranian
meteorite that landed in the ocean which
means for them the one gift from the
heavens that made wakanda unique a
vibranium meteorite was also a gift that
the cosmos gave to the ocean of Earth
but it also poses a question where in
the cosmos did all these cheating I look
forward to exploring that many of the
other questions from this movie in
future videos but ever at Ross which is
the 2018 film and tells sure
we head to MIT remember this is Tony
Stark's alma mater and currently the
college attended by MJ Ned and Flash
sure that's right Dominique Thorne
future ironheart Thor actually initially
auditioned for the role of shuri for the
2018 film and you can tell there's an
inherent Sisterhood between the two
women as intellectual equals kind of
like what we initially saw between Tony
Stark and Peter Parker Tom Holland
origination for Army
conjecture three three plus one this
refers to the 3x plus one problem of the
Colette's conjecture that's the most
famous unsolved problem in mathematics
presumably this is what Riri is actively
working on in her Spare Time inside
bravery's room is the flag of the city
of Chicago that is her hometown and
akoye gets impatient get out of my dorm
get out hey
I'm warning you do not take another step
toward me
see how they teach the children to treat
their guests
I like it hey hey hey hey put him down
put it you hurt yourself come on it's
all right princess small small girl
I am going to give you two options
you can come to wakanda conscious or
unconscious yeah remember in the 2018
film makoya used an itchy wig to go
undercover in the outside world in Korea
now she just covers her head tattoos
with makeup but it presents its own
complication they go to riri's Warehouse
where she said she had to build a
quantum computer to crack her own
encryption Quantum you say I mean the
future technology in the MCU is
certainly Quantum Riri actually could
have been the friend who helped Cassie
Lang build that Quantum Tech that leads
your Avengers yes
not just an ironhearted asking if it's
quote Stark Tech so it's not just that
shuri is building her own exosuit
inspired by Iron Man she is actually
using start text schematics means she
might be building this with Tony's
blessing through one of those MIT grants
like the one that he announced in Civil
War since he would have been like eight
years before this but I assume the grant
program is still functioning I think
it's smart to lean into that instead of
trying to ignore the fact of how Iron
Man it is yeah and they do in the movie
there's so many things that are like so
reminiscent of Iron Man yeah for sure
and I think it brings it it down to
earth it's like okay yeah there's
something I can refer to from Tony
Stark's work and I feel like that is a
way to have Tony still touch and be able
to tech people up but in a way that
doesn't feel as much like you're
skipping past something like it can with
Spider-Man Riri says there's an entire
YouTube channel dedicated to sightings
of me like there's another Peter Parker
parallel with Civil War and homecoming
showing YouTube videos of Peter's
heroics throughout Queens this might
also be an account you can imagine Paula
Khan having something to do with either
posting content there or definitely
replying to it Okoye takes off in a
muscle car short on a motorcycle and
re-ray Suits up in her Mark 1 armor when
it Powers up notice it makes the same
sound effect as Tony starts for pulsers
oh cool
use that Marvel sounds like that's like
my favorite suit of all the suits that
Riri wears in this yes yes a thousand
percent but here there's no full
coverage of the body it's really just
like bars and straps and rigging and zip
ties and she has this chest reactor in
the shape of art the whole Escape is
just very reminiscent of Tony Stark's
initial escape from the cave and his
unfinished Mark 1 suit in the first Iron
Man film Riri makes its rapid climb into
the night sky but she runs out of oxygen
and Falls reminding us a lot of Tony's
first real flight over Los Angeles when
he froze over and fell and just caught
himself at the last second rigor catches
herself here and Glides along the river
Sharia nicoye flee the FBI sure he uses
her spear to Anchor her turn a
government drone closes in on them
Hariri shoots it down and joins the
other two in a victory slide over the
wreckage until
don't think she killed any of those cops
though I feel like that's so bad when
she did though
it's debatable for certain and I mean
that drone collateral damage just blew
up three cruisers at least so I mean
yeah
I feel like it's not so egregious that
you can't chalk it up to like yeah
there's always collateral damage but
also I mean yeah she did murder a few
people or manslaughter like literally
myself like damn you might just kill
those cops right there
it's bold
and whale the actors actually said this
duel between Okoye and natuma took the
longest of any fight sequence in the
film to shoot as they kept having to go
back and read parts of it I love how a
tomb of strike back on her feet she has
a vibranium Spear and she is not used to
ever having to repel other vibranium
with it so defeated shuri requests that
Tyler canal take her and Riri to meet
nemour directly I can imagine it's like
for me yeah imagine like also the time
it you got a specific time of day you
have to shoot it has to be in when this
guy is not freaking bright a prominent
bridge and then you also have to get
everyone in the makeup yeah for hours
and then just the reshooting of upon
reshooting it's just crazy to know like
it's less than 10 minute sequence and
then people just walk moose fun but it
is heartening I do appreciate that since
the discourse has begun a lot of at
least several people we've heard from
have pointed to that as being their
favorite actions
I'm glad that that worked paid off yeah
they'll fall those four months the next
morning Everett Ross arrives at this
crime scene where he meets Valentina
Allegra de Fontaine Julie Louis Dreyfus
the shadowy government figure from the
Falcon Winter Soldier and black widow
who is now established as of this film
as the current CIA director in the MCU
and Ross's ex-wife this is a huge deal
for the political hierarchy of the MCU
this is what I was referring to in my
tweet when I said that the hierarchy
power of the EMC was changing and I said
I'll leave gonna get mad at me when you
find out what it was but yeah I think
it's extremely small I was wondering Val
has been the CIA director because John
Walker didn't really seem to know she
was and the CIA director is a
president-nominated and Senate approved
very public figure well the average
person might not know the CIA director
is it's not like John Walker would know
but either way this means that Val's
recruitment of Walker and recruitment of
Elena belova to kill Hawkeye all of
these things said the full weight of the
US government behind it and now since
Val is going to be leading the
Thunderbolts the Thunderbolts is going
to be a much more public Squad of
killers I think this is definitely going
to tie into secret Invasion and Captain
America New World Order and yeah
Thunderbolts and Val just shot at the
top of my list as scroll suspicious and
ever at Ross right behind her however
Ross is a scroll scroll Ross no I would
be bummed I mean you know I'll happily
Embrace that scroll but he's got such a
personality I think that would undercut
so much of it and I like the idea too of
Val being a scroll and then
whatever rostv keep thinking about their
marriage yes the fact that they were
married I'm like what Drew these two
people together because one guy seems so
nice like he comes across like a little
bit tough especially in Civil War yeah
but he's such a nice guy you know yeah
absolutely and Val's like such a [ __ ]
maybe maybe the real vow when they were
married was nicer and more fun our MCU
CIA director is way hotter than the real
RCA director oh my God yeah the the
public the America the real the
government should take notes reports
losing shuri and Riri the doorways
behind her are now flanked with text on
sacred ground may we find and on the
other side the wisdom of the ancestors
now it actually seems to be a misprint
in the shot of a koye but it is what it
reads later when sure he enters the
ancestral plane version of this room
when it transforms into literal sacred
ground where shuri finds the wisdom I'll
be a complex wisdom of her ancestors
raimonda is reminded that akoye raised
her spear against her own husband
referring to wakati Daniel kaluya's
character from the 2018 film who does
not appear in this movie but Ramona says
that will copy is somewhere that Okoye
can visit him anytime she wishes so this
is that wakabi is alive and well
somewhere Ramona shouts are you Queen of
the most powerful nation in the world
and my entire family
everything God damn it
either with great power comes great loss
Ramona also snaps yes standing at
killmonger's side when she and sure he
had to flee to the mountains something I
was surprised to hear she still have a
grudge over but it's all coming out and
it hurts Okoye resigns for spear say I
get why Ramona would be upset by by all
this I feel like she she reached like
breaking point because she's had to
display such strength of leadership and
I think that scene is so powerful
because that was her boiling point I
can't lose my daughter now I told you
you shouldn't bring her you insisted now
she's gone use your job after all the
[ __ ] you've been through I didn't
even give you crap about what happened
with you I've already cut you the slack
you're asking for killmongeria yeah
totally she doesn't have time to be
emotional it all came out there that was
this is gut wrenching it's kind of crazy
to see that scene because it's it's
gut-wrenching for a koye and it's gut
wrenching for Ramona and they have two
very different sides here and you just
feel so much pain for both of them
because when nikoya is fired you're like
no
Ramona finds Nakia in an orphanage in
Haiti and we catch a quick glimpse of a
boy who later gets revealed in the
post-credit scene to Saint played by
young actor Divine love konadu's son and
the post credit scene is revealed as
t'challa inakiyah Sun t'challa son of
t'challa that's a familiar greeting
between the boy and his grandmother he
was at the premiere
there's 140 meters below kind of a
middle ground man cave for no more to be
alone and to paint because yeah you
can't paint underwater but I also love
that Nemours keeps painting because
that's such a traditional way of keeping
the stories documenting it through
history as opposed to any of the many
modern day technological events
he's like no I'm gonna keep this
tradition going with paintings on the
wall to tell the story yeah it's
beautiful sure he has told to put on a
traditional telecon dress rear says it's
some super villain [ __ ] like Princess
Leia referring to the slave Leia bikini
and Return of the Jedi Belle from Beauty
and the Beast and she says that white
chick from Indiana Jones referring to
when Marion had to put on the white
dress and Raiders of Lost Ark but Bell
from Beauty and the Beast there wasn't
anything that messed up about that I
mean I guess it's kind of weird that a
bunch of like clocks and candles and
dishware is like yeah put on that sexy
dress for that Beast this whole movie's
kind of Stockholm syndrome that's great
she's in the Yucatan in Mexico never
watched that movie it's the same again
there's quite subtitles but the moment
she switches to ancient Mayan the
language of talocon the subtitle
switched the color blue now more brings
shuri into his painting room re-explains
his backstory with his mother in 1571 in
Zama which was the original name of
Tulum which is one of the best preserved
Mayan cities on the coastal Yucatan
Spanish conquistadores gave them small
box now 1571 this would be about 50
years after the eternals witnessed the
Spanish conquering of the Aztec capital
and then parted ways you could argue had
they finished the job we might not have
gotten no more namora says they pray ah
fascinating my eternals are relevant
Jack is the Mayan Reign deity but NASDAQ
mythology that God is named slalok who
rules over slalo Khan namora says shock
LED them to a plant underwater sprouting
from a vibranium Rock their heart-shaped
herb but an herb that grows underwater
namora's mother ingests his plant along
with the rest of the tribe and they wake
up with blue skin gas paper air having
to dive into the water so they can
breathe where their skin turns back a
normal color so other than fascinated by
this detail it'll turn blue only when
they are out of water we see the birth
of nemour as
her son of
Holocaust the wings on his feet and ears
that he says were pointed to the sky and
he calls himself a mutant he says that
he has the ability to age slowly and
breathe both through air and through
water in the MCU we're still Gathering
what the rules of mutant kind are but it
seems like every mute must have some
kind of genetic precondition that leads
to their physical States turning out
different from everyone else but it also
presents the question do all mutants age
slowly because according to the latter
Fox X-Men films that definitely seem to
be the case
well what does the word mutant mean
let's scales get the actual definition
yes it could be like a double meaning
here resulting from showing the effect
of mutation
fascinating an organism that is
different from others of its type
because of permanent changes in its
genes yeah see he could have just been
saying that on a very literal level sure
as opposed to I was a mutant you know
what mutants are you know mutants are
this you're going to be seeing a lot
more of these moving forward I think you
just got one recently it could have been
uh just the right choice of words to
establish him as yes he is a mutant but
maybe in that sentence he was just
referring to himself as this the literal
definition of what a mutant is of our
genes were mutated by this herb and then
I was born with these mutations passed
on genetically without having to take
the herbs so thus I am a mutant yeah
yeah yeah but it's also simultaneously
saying he's a mutant the X-Men you know
well this mother's dying wish young the
more returns to the land where he finds
a slave plantation and a priest says
Thou Art a demon Son Of Satan not yet
Padre but Mephisto is coming soon the
teleconneal burned the plantation and
the more reveals the origin of his given
name that they called him El Nino SI
nemour the boy without love I love the
little little baby
it looks like a Party City costume
a little short little belt one of our
kids are going to be going his name more
in the every pool party not summer these
are really revealing never for a little
boy
cover up son the boy without love which
she embraced as
he has no love for the service world so
Namor it wasn't just to know chuerta
pronouncing it differently they actually
worked in a bit of Spanish wordplay to
cast no more as proudly without love for
humans no more gives Shari a deep
snowboard to show her talocon and at
first I wondered wait where did the
teleconil get these until he raised oh
right yes Salazar and Jackson second
time it hit me was just murdered in nice
have fun nope it doesn't smell bad so
namora takes jury down through this
tunnel in the water which seems to be a
kind of current but I don't know maybe
it's a type of Waypoint to a hidden
Earthly realm kind of like that watery
portal that leads to talo and shung Chi
now I know China and Mexico are
different countries with completely
different cultures and histories I'm
just saying get out of here racist
hidden mythological comes on Earth there
might be a connection there the amazing
and the baltalo yeah for instance
which is revealed from Mayan script
translating to English the way other
location titles translate from wakan
into English the Tamil played the
Mesoamerican ball game Pete's modern
version known as ulama this was played
by Mayan peoples where a rubber ball is
bounced from your hip through a hoop on
the wall you might know it as I did
salute forming their hands kind of in
the shape of a throne but also an open
shark mouth as the telecon throne is a
giant shark Jabba also kind of looks
like hadouken or like I regret that joke
immediately now more show his Central
Palace that is made fully a vibranium
and is lit by a powerful light his own
Golden City that he must protect Nakia
Waits on a line about the sun track
shury's earrings and then dives into a
water hole in the jungle a land-based
waypoint to talocon now notice how
nakia's suit is green the color of her
River tribe but costume designer Ruth e
Carter Incorporated blue to look like a
river snaking Through the Jungle
effectively telling the story of nakia's
rescue plot in the second act the more
gives shuri a gracefully the French same
bracelet worn by his mother both an
olive branch but we later learned the
plant DNA that shuri can use to
re-synthesize the heart-shaped herb so
just to track the jewelry swapping going
on in this movie sure he leaves her
camoyo bead bracelet for Ross to find
technically Val bug that bracelet but
she keeps her earrings which is how they
track her down meanwhile no more notices
that shuri's wrist is bare as she
surrenders himself to him which she
knows that he won't see is suspicious
because she was not wearing that
bracelet earlier at the Riverside fire
ritual smart Quest so nomore gives her a
bracelet which becomes the Cure that
she's been seeking throughout this whole
film I love it when costumes
symbolic function in the film shuri
tells no more yes yes yeah good catch we
finally asked for help she couldn't now
this is a nod to Chadwick Boseman in
real life who was diagnosed with colon
cancer in 2016 and he told pretty much
no one he suffered in silence while
shooting Black Panther and infinity war
and end game Ryan coogler recently told
Anna he see coats in a podcast that he
noticed Bozeman would struggle during
the warrior fall scenes in the 2018 film
and at the time coogler didn't really
know why some days when I would find him
doing things that were kind of
inexplicable like we would do these
these things in the water you know the
waterfall stuff so it would take him
like a long time to warm back up like
you have to be in like in a warm intake
like a long time and I'll be like I'll
be like man I'll be like that's odd you
know you know I'm saying things like
that or you know some some days I was
Finding just like incredibly sad but
looking back I'm like oh man my man's
was dying it's a shocking thing to
realize and it's also a thing where it's
like oh yeah I can't quit If he if he
did all that while he was going through
that you know this is just grief so it's
like we gotta push through that is so
freaking powerful like it's
heartbreaking but also inspiring in many
ways it's such perseverance and
discipline mind over body yeah and and
some of the wildest ways you know like
he didn't want to be looked at it I
don't know what it was specifically I
don't want anyone want to try to guess
what it was that Chadwick Boseman uh was
probably going through you know clearly
he was incredibly private about it to
know that and like even the people
around him just weren't made aware of it
and he didn't want to put that out there
it still fought through it it's just
that's just so insane to me it's so
insane yeah and the fact that you can't
tell by looking at it to like the amount
of internal like it makes you wonder on
top of all the other preparation
physical and as an actor like what
mental wherewithal and spiritual
wherewithal had to have been drawn from
to sell those scenes and to commit to
doing that instead of like you know you
you have a tremendous illness you have
every excuse in a lot of ways to you
know not necessarily go that far to
committing to this gift to everybody you
know to me I'm like yeah that's like a
real life leader in a real life Warrior
and so that's another reason why I think
it was important to do a movie that
really honors Chadwick Postman no more
tells shuri my ancestors would often say
only the most broken people can be great
leaders he's trying to appeal to her
grief as a kind of complement of wisdom
but the more reveals the whole point of
all this that he plans to attack the
surface world preemptively and he wants
straight to get wakanda to join them in
that war and while he seems crazy they
see mikatsu converts that to be
essentially the case the Secretary of
State tells Val and Ross that the
president plans to invade wakanda the
more meets Ramon on the beach and warns
her that he will kill her if any further
intrusions happen to telecon Meanwhile
Nakia arrives in history and riri's
Telecom he'll guard with a fatal blast
sure he reunites with her mother no more
returns to find that dying guard and
nomura goats him to strike back so no
more descends to his sharkbone throne
where it looks like the teeth are
actually made of vibranium he wears a
feathered serpent headpiece of cuckoo
Khan I like the symbolic contrast in the
directional coronation of the two King
wakanda's ruler Rises up from the
ancestral plane to set the throne
telecon's ruler descends down from the
Sun to sit that Throne telecon angrily
rallies his people to war
Nakia reunites with the koye in wakanda
okoya says that Nikia left right after
thanos's attack when you left without
saying a word
you did
how you regret not being there with all
of you it was not easy
he was King and black panther to
everyone
to me
this means that Nakia was pregnant with
t'challa's son at the time of thanos's
snap in the Battle of wakanda and notice
how here Nakia catches herself she
almost says t'challa was also the father
to her son but she just says that he was
everything which she was behind Nakia
water just slowly starts to flood into
the streets I don't even notice it at
first okoya just begins to say we are
under attack but then the water bombs
explode throughout the streets now Namor
flooding wakanda was a plot point in
2012 Avengers vs X-Men comic storyline
that's when the Phoenix Force possesses
Neymar and uses him to flood wakanda
when the nation Harbors Avengers Neymar
and t'challa have a bitter hatred for
each other ever since that in the comics
okay grabs a kid as the water gushes and
hands him off Ayo and the other door
milage save some rescue workers who get
enchanted by the teleconneal siren songs
shuri and Anika pilot an aircraft to
save a trolley we actually saw one of
these on the streets in the 2018 film
it's just pretty satisfying to see all
levels of wakandans immediately spring
in to help each other namora joins atuma
and nomura on the shoreline and it's
like an actual civilians being held tap
on his arm and the more punches him
right in the chest breaking his chest
armor right now
I know if he's rounding up water is the
strongest Hulk I actually recently broke
the Avatar of a God that kind of checks
out with the mcu's internal Logic the
more zigzags through the air defenses he
does his mid-air turn with his foot
passing the camera showing his ankle
Wings flapping over time no more flies
up to the throne room to face off with
ramonda and Riri inside he stabs his
spear into the glass and cracks it then
throws water grenades and floods the
room Ramon is able to save Riri but she
drowns and sure he is inconsolable so
shuri has to go through another Royal
burial this time for her mother now
ironically my damn bold move funeral
garments before she left him to be used
again just imagine how horrible it is
you just were closer to your brother's
funeral and before they even have a
chance to gather Dusty gotta put them
back on for your mother I do want to put
this I put this on the live stream but I
do think that I wish we had a scene of
Riri afterwards that dealt with her
feeling like
guilty I've heard the criticisms of Riri
Williams in this film she's feeling like
an iron heart setup I was saying in the
live stream I think what would have
really helped Focus up her narrative in
the film and the integral part of her
being here would have been if after
Ramona dies you know because in the
whole movie she's kind of like I didn't
even do anything why is he coming after
me and I didn't I didn't intend for any
of this but then after Ramona dies being
like it's feeling like it's her fault
Ramona died because Ramona tried saving
her went to save her and then none of
this maybe would have happened if Riri
didn't do any of this and then sure he
could have like motivated her to be like
well then you just gotta put the
everything you do to do something good
and help me fight back yeah I mean think
of how I must be feeling if I'm in a
fight you can join me yeah and together
we can at least make something better it
would have made Earhart's appearance too
in the finale feel even cooler and more
powerful and like yeah make her part of
the Journey of grief and guilt and all
that too and then she has a line about
her dad in the end yeah it could
resonate over that together yeah the
answer woes is literally tattooed on her
hand a double helix configuration with
orbs her attempt at the recipe for the
heart-shaped herb and now on the same
wrist is the final ingredient she needs
nemour's mother's bracelet that is made
from that plant meanwhile Val confronts
her ex-husband Ross on his contact with
wakanda Anderson Cooper cameos again but
this time the new sticker reads Ritson
signed trade pact with new Asgard to
create something but this is not to the
new U.S president who's gonna be played
by Dermot Mulroney in secret invasions
oh no way U.S president secretary of
state Toby Ziegler ncia director Val
it's still great they're really setting
up secret information in this movie
is
it bring him against the United States
and asked Valance she's ever thought
what the U.S would be doing if we were
the only country in the world to add
vibranium and Val's response is
interesting she says oh I actually dream
about that I think it's a little ahead
that one of Val's objectives is to amass
all the vibranium and weaponry under
government control or at least under her
control and maybe the mission she's
going to deploy the Thunderbolts on is
an invasion of or a heist from wakanda
or since Bucky's lead in that team may
be a collaboration with the door milage
to steal back vibranium from some other
third party who steals it like the real
intelligencia I don't feel like Bucky
would ever no matter if he's part of the
Thunderball he is not going to invade he
will be inciting Institute of film they
try to test him with task him with this
Mission and he just quits yeah there's
no way he's attacking wakanda so the
Golden City evacuates to the Jabari
Outpost shury and reread deduce that
nemour absorbs oxygen through his skin
and thus will be weakened by dehydration
Rivier gets to work on new Iron Art
harmer made from vibranium she hammers
out a piece in the shape of a heart
sharing gives Okoye her completed
Midnight Angel suit in the comics
sure he is able to synthesize the
heart-shaped her of DNA from the
bracelet and when it prints it
successfully glows so sure he sips the
liquid and falls into the ancestral
plane as not pray for her now
structurally this mirrors the leap of
faith at the end of Act 2 in the 2018
film when the women resurrected t'challa
to restore wakanda's protector shuri
immediately finds herself in an
ancestral plane mirror of the real world
underwater in the flooded throne room in
the exact same spot where her mother
Ramona's life left her body just like
how when killmonger went to the
ancestral plane he visited the exact
spot of his parents tragic death sure he
swims up to the surface and she's again
wearing her White Funeral garments but
as she Rises out of the water her
clothes are dry I must have shot that
backwards Leticia Wright and Ryan
coogler might have shot this in Reverse
yeah yeah you see there is someone
sitting on the throne behind her
suddenly we all feel a mix of dread
because none of us want to see a CGI
Recreation of Chadwick Boseman it can't
be him it can't be so instead the ghost
who greets us is killmonger Michael B
Jordan making a surprise Cameo which
comes that's both the relief but also an
intriguing Haunting of its own the scene
that follows is my favorite scene in the
film cutting deep to the core conflict
of this film while also
recontextualizing everything we saw in
the 2018 film remember the answer extra
plane is not an objective afterlife it's
really a personalized Vision where the
visitor is able to confront their
ancestors there's some Cosmic forces at
play that decide who you actually need
to talk to one could say this is a
request coming from one's own soul but
for t'challa it was to rage against his
father for killing and jobu and
abandoning for killmonger it was his
chance to revisit the Oakland apartment
where his father died but who does
Sherry see she sees her cousin
killmonger who taunts her saying you
chose me and he challenges her for not
even believing the ancestral plane was
real but just took the Earth for the
same reason he did to avenge Fallen
ancestors now remember as much as this
is killmonger talking to her we could
totally look at this as shuri having a
conversation with herself and all of a
sudden I'm guessing she's been doing
about killmonger over the past several
years so why did Sherry seek killmonger
she already chose him earlier in the
film when she said at that Riverside
campfire that she wanted to burn the
world down that was killmonger's goal
and notice how in this scene the throne
room ignites the same way killmonger set
the heart-shaped herb garden Ablaze and
left Sherry with that medical crisis
here killmonger defends himself he says
I had the courage do what was necessary
to change wakanda how many people like
your scientists to wakanda protect
before I took the throne cowards those
are the Panthers who came before me and
before t'challa sure he tells killmonger
that he was coward we're taking a last
Urban burning the rest out of fear of
being replaced that he left wakanda with
no protector and that's a challenge
Ramona's blood is on his hands the
killmonger responds don't you dare take
that away from your mother she
sacrificed her life to protect a girl
from The Lost tribe your father he was a
hypocrite he would have killed that girl
[ __ ] he killed his own brother t'challa
he was too Noble he led a man who killed
your father live and here you stand are
you gonna be Noble like your brother or
take care of business like me killmonger
calls Riri a member of this tribe which
is how he saw himself and all other
black people outside of wakanda the
lives that he fought for killmonger also
invokes Zemo who killed tachaka and
t'challa for gave Zemo at the end of
Civil War I like to think that Zemo at
this moment stiffened in his cell on the
Wrath feeling to shiver down his spine
so then just resume dancing
to see killmonger eternally sitting on
the throne now again shuri has
subconsciously summoned him here but
this visual presents a hypothetical that
killmonger could be in a kind of Hell of
his own making where he's sitting on the
the throne that he always wanted but
ruling over a vacant dead kingdom while
all other Panther ancestors joined
together in a communion as Panthers in a
tree killmonger tragically will always
be part of a lost tribe of one oh [ __ ]
yeah that's a great Point that's a
really great deep point that even in the
ancestral plane just a visual I'm sure
like especially
if he's still
is behaving that way man after death it
thinks that way I could see him being
like oh [ __ ]
we're dead there's plenty of ancestral
plane for you to take up don't just come
over here with your bad energy all right
you're trying to be wise in a turn over
here there's no more grudges it's always
gonna be a load out there
no I mean that's the powerful part of
this shury's whole dilemma is she could
either go the path of her brother or go
the path to killmonger you know
obviously we know which passion ends up
taking I think that's one of the
beautiful conflicts and a way of
honoring what's come before again so
yeah
that was that was funny though
yeah man it'll be a what if episode that
just all takes place in the ancestral
plane and the workplace comedy so that I
thought he might have softened up a
little bit
nope this scene ends before Sherry can
even answer killmonger's question
framing it as a haunting nightmare that
she's still trying to figure out for the
rest of the film she's afraid to tell
others who she saw in that Vision out of
shame because killmonger was a symptom
of her own moral illness that this
physician still needs to heal but sure
he still has super strength and she
suits up in a new suit she places her
helmet beside the helmet of her brother
the helmet that she carried in the
opening funeral scenes now she has a
helmet of her own and sure he joins
everyone else at the Jabari Outpost
fully suited up interesting how she
joins by descending from above the way
no more set his throne sure he does not
rise up she drops down she's still being
driven by the misguided Vengeance that
guides into more and guided killmonger
when she lands I like how the impact
spreads via purple kinetic energy as her
suit absorbs the shock of it I mean the
Black Panther Falls and lands yeah a lot
several times
I mean it's a it's nice for her first
appearance that way but also I mean you
know there's a lot of jumping off and
Landing a lot of other characters do
that too I'm sure it was really did it
feel everyone with you on the everything
in talocon when Neymar was doing it but
at this moment if she had landed on a
throne then then maybe she's just coming
to talk with everybody you know you know
remember she's gonna rise up first to
the ground
here to hold on the ground and fly up
and through it can we carve out a castle
in a trap door so I can get to this her
helmet has a DOT pattern that matches
the war paint that she's worn from past
battles also on her gauntlets are open
Panther moths sure he leads wakandas out
to the ocean and lures the teleconil in
battle she chants Evon Bay that was
t'challa's war Cripe in the Battle of
wakanda infinity War since the Moore's
punch broke his old chest plate mbaku
suits up with new armor burying the face
of Hanuman that's the APD the Jabari
worship the telekinil attacked for the
backs of blue whales and orcas their
Shields I'm pretty sure the shells of
sea turtles awesome pulsing devices the
wakandans use to try to subdue them
actually Jessica Clemens interviewed
Alex lubinali and Mabel Cadena asking
about their underwater work for this
film and Alex confirmed that Mabel holds
the record she's the champ are you
holding the breath how long
no yeah no no wow you're gonna say that
loud
six minutes you can hold your breath
underwater
[Music]
surrounded by glowing indicators much
like Iron Man's heads up display
whatever controls reads Max per I like
how she also installed some foot
thrusters similar to Tony's Mark 50
armor in Infinity War Riri shoots it
into more from behind but he's able to
dodge the blast without looking crazy
good reflexes they're able to snare no
more on the Royal Talent fighter sure he
uses hand mounted Sonic cannons to repel
the telekineal like the ones that's used
on killmonger in the 2018 film she claws
down the side of the boat kicking one
telekineal throwing another Barrel
rolling and then sliding down since both
her claws and the whole of this boat are
made a vibranium they released blue
Sparks from the friction and from here
she leaps into the Royal Talon fighter
where she tries to fly no more to a
nearby desert to finish him off but
before they get there he's able to use
his spear to stab through the fighter
and wreck the engine causing it to crash
leading to this brutal Showdown the
claws come out sure and the more Slug It
Out She Dodges this hook and goes low
slicing off some of his ankle Wings he
impales you on his spear so since it's
pure vibranium it goes through her
suit's vibranium weed I don't know why
when they when it pulls off that
feathered wing it just you can feel it
right like oh yeah like I don't know
what it's like to have one of those but
for some reason you're just like oh that
seems really I feel I feel like it's
painful I think it's the placement
because the ankle the ankle like anytime
you watch a horror movie and someone
gets like I think that it was there the
Evil Dead pencil gag or something like
ankle I think is already an icky place
for uh any kind of you know painful gag
and also too you know it's a wing so
it's like a smaller appendage so I think
you can relate it to like a finger or a
toe or a part of a foot you know like
you can feel the smaller more intimate
pains than if it had just been like I'm
gonna cut you in half it seems like it's
all over as her life Fades she's
transported back to the ancestral plane
the burning Throne Room briefly her
greatest fear that being consumed with
killmonger's ventral rage has led her to
death but instead she now rejects that
path she claws off the spear she pulls
herself off a bit somehow leaving no
blood on the shaft of that spear okay
and leaps over to more and lands before
it and she uses the exploding jet engine
most effective just by drying him out
even further and as she holds the blade
to his throat both Fighters are close to
death and they sink in this fascinating
interlocking visions of their ancestors
for sure the conflicts of the past
rewind we see the flooding in the
battles before reversing symbolizing her
wounds beginning to heal both the
physical wounds in her suit and her
psychological illness her mind is
retracing its steps back to the mutually
peaceful kingdoms of wakanda and finally
shuri sees the ancestor she wanted to
see in the ancestral plane a vision of
her mother Ramona who says show him who
you are and sure he tells them more to
yield so that Their Kingdoms can protect
each other no more looks at but sure he
what does he see he sees the vision of
his mother reaching down to him on the
sacred ground every man there's a mother
of their ancestors a closing montages
shuri replanting the heart-shaped herb
garden in t'challa's Grain site she
greets Riri in the lab and makes a
return didn't point out how the mirrors
on the bridge earlier not having this
super vibrating it's probably a good
idea because this way where he was going
to be set up to build a new DIY armor
set in Iron Heart on Disney Plus in 2023
we return to Warrior balls but instead
of shuri coming out of the royal Talent
fighter it's mbaku he says the Black
Panther shuri sends her regards but in
Baku wishes to challenge for the throne
this sets up embaku to be the new ruler
of wakanda while sure he continues to be
black panther at least an intermediary
one we catch it back with him fights
with a giant carrot cave seems as though
things are still a bit unresolved and we
realize no more has been painting all
this time a depiction of himself and a
panther locked in battle Okoye rescues
Ross from captivity making him a
fugitive from the American government
and leaving Okoye in her Midnight Angel
suit finally with some headgear that
she's comfortable in the final scene
brings her into a beach in Haiti where
she finally allows herself to burn her
funeral garments she closed her eyes and
meditates and she flashes back to the
images of t'challa from the 2018 film
when he walked down the hallway to her
lab and gave his sister their handshake
when she placed his necklace suit on him
after he resurrected the first time he
walked into the the throne room is King
and she finally breathes to let go of
her brother she and we are lulled by
Rihanna's lift me up the lyrics of which
become Sheree's prayer to her brother
Lift Me Up Hold Me Down hold me close
safe and sound now burning in a hopeless
dream Echoes the fire of the despair
that she felt in her nightmare with
Kilmer in the second verse that part
becomes drowning in an Endless Sea a
contrast to Fire and Water there but
both represent killmonger and no more
dragging shuri down into violence which
is why the chorus comes back to the
prayer of lift me up and in the
post-credits scene her prayers are
answered exactly you see that's like
when we were talking about in the live
stream I was saying that like I think
it's a great intermission song for right
after the end credits and before the
what the post-credits is it's like the
perfect in between for it and I think
it's one of the best closing credit
songs the mcu's ever had yeah songs you
know they're all songs but they're you
know like with lyrics and stuff that are
poignant and meaningful and reflective
of the film and I think it's a perfectly
apt song for it oh yeah well and the way
the first movie had such a Big Splash
with like we've got this curated
soundtrack and Marvel doesn't do yeah
like spot music soundtrack scores
usually yeah it's like there's not a lot
of songs Amalgamated from artists and
this felt like a way to you know
continue that tradition but also focus
it in on one specific piece and in the
post-credits scene her prayers are
answered Nakia introduces Sherry to her
nephew to Saint Sherry says the name to
Saint carries a history referring to to
Saint the Overture sorry if I
mispronounced that my prince sucks but
this guy was awesome called the black
Napoleon the father of Haiti who in 1791
led a successful slave revolt against
the French and one Haitian Independence
I think what I love most about this line
is that it signals sure he has through
her wakandan Outreach centers that she
built with t'challa has begun to learn
more black history from outside wakanda
and has begun to reconnect with that
lost tribe that killmonger fought for I
mean I don't know sure he's pretty smart
maybe she already knew this stuff but it
did seem like in the 2018 film all she
really seemed to know about the outside
world was like Disneyland and Back to
the Future too Saint reveals that his
real name is t'challa son of King
t'challa he would be no more than six or
seven years old so we would need a bit
of a time job before we see any real
superhero action from this kid even if
you were to join a group like the Young
Avengers but a new t'challa lives he has
his whole life ahead of him and he knows
where he comes from and who his baba was
the Black Panther is not a burden sure
you must carry alone anymore her brother
is gone but wakanda is forever follow me
on Tick Tock wakanda forever forever
rockstars subscribe to new rockstars for
more analysis of everything you love
thanks for watching bye
epic breakdown man very beautiful very
well done beautifully done my God
four and a half of that black panther
today for us yep longer than the movie
itself like just when I thought I
couldn't appreciate the movie more here
comes Voss that's beautiful thank you
for putting that together new rock stars
team you guys did an excellent excellent
job guys subscribe leave a like thanks
for the pain
Daniel gallacher Daniel happy belated
birthday it was your birthday just a
couple of days ago Dude so I hope it was
a good one we are honoring our patrons
right now who have been the most loyal
to us over the years and you've been a
patron of ours for 51 months that is a
very obnoxiously long time to not have
illegally shipped us things from the
pharmacy that you work at what is your
deal Manny's Danny so much
[Music]
and but 51 months is a very long time so
I know in Scotland you guys didn't
celebrate Thanksgiving because you're
not American meaning you're not cool but
regardless uh I wanted to say thank you
for being just as awesome as you are and
as um gracious as you have been this
entire time and
it's it's an absolute joy to have you in
our lives so wish you a Merry Christmas
I hope you have a wonderful 2023 and uh
is this you in the thumbnail or is that
your girlfriend zoom in I think this is
his girlfriend because he's been like
talking nuts no that's Daniel but you
are beautiful enough you know what it is
the stuff in the background made it look
like long hair yeah
yeah all right and the and the yeah the
the bits on your shirt almost yeah
this is a hot white girlfriend yeah but
you're just a hot hot white person a new
hot white man instead yeah you're the
real Everett Ross of the real rejects
Nation Daniel Gallagher
foreign